if we had a movie then right say they
decide they're going to go cinematic
they're going to make a movie what do we
actually want now you hate this idea you
hate it
so what do you want if I was if I was
looking at it like this is what would
make what I think would be entertaining
I'd want a compelling villain maybe for
someone from the past Like a Villain
that maybe hasn't that hasn't had his
end the Loose Ends all wrapped up maybe
that could return
Anubis could come back he's not
technically dead he's not he's just In
Perpetual fighting with omrid Asylum but
who's to say he didn't get the upper
hand at some point he could return and
that could be an interesting story
how about
it's not Anubis doesn't necessarily
return but the movie is about his
followers trying
to free him to get him to allow him to
return
so the whole point is to stop the
followers from doing whatever it is
they're going to do to
they're all trying to ascend so they can
go and fight Oma
what where did you go to that no there
could be a million ways they could bring
it
he's ascended the only way that his
followers would be able to interact with
him or the person battling him would be
for them to ascend they're building an
Anubis magnet and when they turn it on
it'll just suck his energy being to the
magnet